[Musique]
on vient y croyez vous qu'il y ait deux
papas peluche mais faute rococo comptait
bien sur vos droits
et il manque
[Musique]
mon courrier il avait pourtant sorti
tant pis je vais en prendre un autre au
piège voilà les jambes et monsieur
bougon
[Musique]
non
au genou bon train quoi à mon âge c'est
ridicule
oh mais je vous assure que je comprends
pas du tout il vous ne comprenez pas moi
j'ai compris toi mon gars tu ne perd
rien pour attendre
[Musique]
et
on fait tout et oui mon cher tout
[Musique]
m
et
[Musique]
[Rires]
on m'a volé mon fait tout bien moi mon
sac à main mais je sais qui est le
voleur 15 avec moi
[Musique]
pour sac à main qu'est-ce qu'il ya la
guerre
alors vous avez recommencer recommencer
quoi monsieur bougon vous n'avez pas
honte honte de quoi c'est lui le
coupable
et bien croyez vous qu'il y ait de pâte
à pêcher mais votre déco beauté bien sûr
photo à
ouattara parce que claude attendant ils
ont manqué
[Musique]